you guys really seem to like my video 20
minimalist money saving tips that is why
i'm here to share with you 20 more ways
to save money but make sure you stick to
the end because i saved the best tip for
laughs welcome to yessi tv where you can
find weekly videos on minimalism and
positive mindset to help you live a
simpler happier life before we continue
i want to give a shout out to song thank
you for stopping by to share your
comments and share your awesome content
so tip number one is pretty simple it's
to take shorter showers and to lower
your temperature on your water heater
the department of energy recommends 120
degrees fahrenheit to save money on
energy this is something that's so
simple but it saves you money without
even having to think about it
tip number two is to change your light
bulbs an 8 to 9 watt led bulb can emit
just as much light oftentimes as a 60
watt incandescent bulb so if you're
going to replace these opt for an led
instead
tip number three
food food is often a huge expense for us
so cut down on your waste by freezing
fruits or veggies that are about to go
bad for example we often keep bananas on
stock all the time but whenever we have
several that get ripe what we do is we
end up putting them in the freezer so
that we can use for smoothies and frozen
veggies can make for really good soups
as well so try to reduce your waste in
this way
tip number four is to unplug things that
are not in use i don't know if you've
ever heard of the term energy vampires
but things like your blenders or your
mixers that are plugged in but they're
not in use are actually using a bit of
electricity so when you're not using
things like these just unplug them
tip number five is keep a wish list
usually for me i keep it for a few days
for shorter expenses or several days
even weeks if it's a major expense by
doing this i give myself the chance to
think about whether i really need it or
not or if i just want it this helps keep
me from making impulsive purchases and
then just ending up with more clutter
and less money
quit unhealthy expensive habits such as
drinking alcohol buying lottery tickets
and smoking these are habits that can
add up to so much money and they're
often overlooked for example let's say
that somebody spends fifteen dollars a
week on alcohol and lottery tickets over
the course of 20 years that's over
fifteen thousand dollars and if those
fifteen thousand dollars had been
invested they could add up to so much
more
so not only do you lose the money but
it's detrimental to your health so try
to do whatever you can to stop those
habits
[Music]
tip number seven is similar to tip
number five and it is don't go to a
store without a list when you go
shopping without a plan it's usually
when you end up with everything else
besides the item that you actually went
in to buy let me know in the comments
has this ever happened to you that you
go into the store buying let's say
bananas and you end up with everything
but the bananas
tip number eight is buy used take
advantage of online shopping stores
where you can actually look for the
specific item that you're searching for
or
shop at secondhand stores you could be
surprised that oftentimes you can find
name brands at secondhand stores and
good quality as well
but
do make sure that as i mentioned in my
previous video you do not skimp out on
quality because otherwise you're just
going to spend an extra amount of money
to buy the item that actually worked for
you
tip number nine make it automatic
if saving money for you is something
that's difficult to do then save
yourself that stress of thinking about
it and set up a savings account to where
it automatically sends a specific amount
whether it's every week or every month
personally i would do every week because
monthly it's kind of hard to gauge
how much money you can do and if you do
weekly you can do a shorter amount
something that's small and easy to do
for you by making it automatic you're
making it a priority and you're making
sure that it's actually going to happen
and this doesn't have to be a huge
amount as you start building up and
start finding new ways to save money or
perhaps if you're making more money then
you can increase these amounts but at
least start
tip number 10 skip desserts and drinks
at restaurants
water is basically free and all these
things are basically just loaded with
sugar you don't need them in your body
they're an extra expense and oftentimes
drink can be even up to like three
dollars and imagine if every single time
you go to a restaurant you get a drink
how much money you're spending
tip number 11 buy generic brands
a lot of prescriptions and even grocery
items have the same ingredients in them
but they have a huge price difference
between generic and name brand so if you
can try to opt mostly for generic brands
and you will save so much cash
number 12 ask for a discount what's the
worst that can happen they say no if
they do then at least you practiced so
that you maybe get a yes next time
tip number 13 is not for the weak
hearted it's not that serious just cut
your own hair do your own brows nails
all that personal care stuff if you've
never done this before it can be a bit
scary to just jab some scissors in your
hair or rip off your eyebrows yourself
but there's a lot of great youtube
videos out there where you can learn how
to do these things yourself so kind of
along with the previous video diy and do
all of these personal care things
yourself
tip number 14 was something that i used
to do when i had very poor self-control
over how i spent my money and this was
leave my wallet at home or in my locker
when i went to work
this helped me to eliminate even the
chance of me chunking my home brought
lunch and buying it out instead it also
kind of forced me because this was kind
of a new ingrained habit in me to take
my lunch to work which i mentioned in my
previous video i would however say that
you should probably have a few dollars
of extra cash just in case you have a
flat tire or something or you need some
gas
but it would only be for emergencies and
know that chocolate donut is not an
emergency
sorry
number 15 did someone say party
if you're having a party consider having
a potluck or maybe doing something
that's free outdoors such as in a public
park
sometimes when we're planning a party we
get so caught up in the decorations and
having the perfect venue that we forget
that it's actually about the experience
and the people that are there and i
don't know about you but i like a good
potluck
tip number 16
use coupons but know that if you're
spending extra money on a particular
offer you're not actually saving money
did i actually save money when i took a
buy one get one half offer and i bought
two name brand purses
no i didn't need them but i talked
myself into it because it's a great
offer and it's the buy one get one
don't do that to yourself
the next time you see a special sale or
a great offer that you think you can't
pass out on try to really think if
you're actually needing this item and if
you're really going to use it because
otherwise you're really only spending
extra money you're not saving
number 17 may not be for everybody and
it's to adopt a minimalist style capsule
wardrobe
let me know if this has ever happened to
you have you ever purchased this
particular shirt that matched nothing
else in your closet so you ended up
having to buy new shoes a new belt or
new pants just to match with that extra
shirt you can avoid those extra hassles
and extra expense by buying things that
are more neutral in color and that don't
have very flashy patterns because
oftentimes what ends up happening is
that you do have to end up buying this
pair of shoes to match the shirt to
match this watch
and you're just adding more and more and
more
and at the end of the day you barely
wear half of it
so by buying things that are neutral in
color that don't have too flashy of
patterns you are eliminating extra
expense that you're going to have to
spend in order to match the rest of your
clothes
and you kind of simplify your day-to-day
because you're not thinking i have
nothing to wear
[Music]
tip number 18 if you're traveling or
going on a road trip try really hard to
anticipate to pack all of the items that
you might need while you're there so
that you don't have to buy them while
you're there i can't tell you the number
of times we've had to buy a blanket
because we didn't think to take one or a
jacket or a charger
little items like that that you already
have in your home
are just making you spend even more
money
plus it's really annoying to have to buy
something that you already own it's just
several miles away so make a list
tip number 19
always research big purchases before you
make them when my husband and i needed
to buy a stove for our house we ended up
researching several stores within our
area and we found a 200 difference
between two different stores
the same exact stove so just make it a
habit to look before you buy
tip number 20 is i think by far my most
favorite and the most important and it's
invest in yourself not in your ego
what i mean by this is don't buy things
to please other people or to make other
people think a certain way of you
instead invest and i don't necessarily
mean money but invest time in yourself
take the time to read books to gain
knowledge or to learn new skills and
crafts one of my personal favorites
since libraries are closed right now is
to do audio books and you can oftentimes
get these for free i personally have
this hoopla app where i can actually get
books from my local library for free
using my library card so you don't have
to spend money to gain knowledge but
it's so important because leaders are
readers
so if you want to save money great but
make it be because you want to be better
as a whole you want to be better
physically spiritually mentally
financially as a person grow and what
better way than to invest in yourself i
hope that these tips help you learn how
to save money but make sure that you do
not skip out on this step because this
is what's going to get you to the next
level
i so hope that you found these tips
helpful if you have any more of your own
please share them in the comments and if
you like this video please like and
subscribe so you won't miss out on other
videos like these thank you so much bye
[Music]